[Music]
we clapped and we cheered
while they risked their lives to save
ours
now we're being asked to make another
sacrifice
a national lockdown to stop our nhs
from being overwhelmed in terms of
deaths over the winter
there's the potential for this to be
twice as bad
or more in terms of the first way
compared to the first wave
over the next six weeks into early
december
the numbers exceed the numbers of
hospitalizations in the first wave peak
the government has been warned that if
it fails to act now
by december the nhs will run out of all
capacity there's a rise in number of
people going into hospital with covid
over time
it is now quite a high level and if
things went wrong the
margin of error is very very small we
have very little headroom
even uh in the one area where there is
some flattening at the moment
the warnings have been sounded for weeks
hospitals in some regions
are already at capacity and dealing with
a surge in cases
at this rate the capacity warnings would
come true
even after elective procedures are
canceled
we were expecting last time that other
nhs activity would continue
to a certain extent and for whatever
reason it didn't happen
but we're really clear and we want to
get the message out to the public that
covert in the community needs to be
kept at as low a level as we possibly
can so that we can continue to give
healthcare to everybody else in the nhs
who needs to have it as well
and that hope to continue treatment for
all
is one of the most important reasons for
acting
now as we entered into the first wave
there was the fear of the unknown
this time it's a fear of the known
hospitals are much better drilled at
creating surge capacity
and there are scientific advancements
for patients
in critical care two little girls help a
fairy
the challenge for the nhs this time
around is to keep hospitals open
for covered and non-covet patients
that's why news of the lockdown fills
haley burrows with dread
she's been waiting for a hysterectomy
since last year
when her endometriosis was diagnosed
they've told me in november a year ago
that i needed it done in an emergency
setting very quickly
and it's been a year and we know the
pandemic is only getting worse and it's
going to be a long time before
clinics are up and running and surgeries
are going to be open again
when am i going to get it am i going to
get it am i going to have to live like
this
for the next year or so i don't feel
like i can this time there is no
national directive to stop routine
operations
but some trusts have already been forced
to pause non-emergency operations
again oh my god be careful you're at
your butter
the worry for hayley and thousands of
other patients like her
is that theirs might be two harshest
joshie
sky news
you